most of the debris outside this girls
school may be gone
but not the anger and grief among the
people of dashtabarchi
dozens of students mostly girls were
killed
as they were leaving school three bomb
blasts
cutting their lives short
whoever comes and commits an act of
terror should be prevented and punished
that no other group conducts such kind
of criminal activities in the future
the security forces come to the scene
after the attack and create more chaos
that will never help prevent such brutal
attacks
witnesses say the attack appeared well
coordinated
and intended to kill as many children as
possible
this is the school's gate and as the
girls were coming out a car bomb
and two ids exploded almost
back to back in three different parts of
the road
outside the school the taliban has
denied responsibility and
blamed isil the government says the
taliban is behind the attack
there are more than 20 terrorist groups
operating in afghanistan
peace talks between the taliban and the
afghan government
are at an impasse and some analysts say
even if they reach a peace deal
stability in the country
is not guaranteed a time when the
taliban are not
claiming the responsibility for such
attacks
this means that there are other actors
involved in afghanistan who has the
capacity of
challenging the state and the stability
and peace of afghanistan
which again means that the international
society
community is leaving an unfinished
chapter behind
the attack was carried out as violence
is rising across the country
and foreign troops look to complete
their withdrawal
in the coming months the hazara ethnic
minority
lives in the dashtabatshi neighborhood
and has been repeatedly attacked in
recent years
its members have called on the
government to protect them
isil has claimed several of the attacks
we will investigate and find the
perpetrators we're working very hard
that they should be brought to justice
but justice has rarely been served to
the victims
of the many attacks in dashtabarchi
and so once more they bury their dead
and pray for the carnage to end fellow
controvery al jazeera
kabul